upward JLo and a rods date night run-in
with her ex guys is there anything worse
than running into an ex while you're out
with your new side piece well Jennifer
Lopez was this close from believin out
my worst nightmare when she and a rod
hit up Craig's restaurant in West
Hollywood that's where her former flame
beau Casper Smart was also dining at the
same time let me remind you JLo and her
former backup dancer were together for
nearly five years and broke up in 2016
and then she started dating a rod and I
witness tells et the exes not see or
speak to each other adding it was just a
coincidence they were both there but
crazy that j.lo has had a public run-in
with beau Casper Smart before the singer
of bestie Leah Remini were having a
little girls die at a nightclub in LA
when the pair ran into him listen and
send me but love between the former
flames just last year beau told us he's
happy for JLo even though she's moved on
I want nothing but the best and love you
know good friends you know I mean just
nothing but like respect and love for
each other
you